Wounded in similar ways Wounded in similar ways It sounds like something that a hippie would say But the truth is we're wounded in similar ways Hey guys, it's Joel And I've had a couple questions where someone wanted me to explain why I said something kind of a quick article to kind of summarize some of those things neatly so that you didn't have to go back and listen to two years or read two years worth of stuff. So this article is called The Illusion of Progress, How Psychotherapy Lost Its
以相似的方式受伤 以相似的方式受伤 这听起来像是嬉皮士会说的话，但事实是，我们确实以相似的方式受伤。嘿，大家好，我是乔尔。我收到了一些问题，有人希望我解释为什么我会说某些话，所以我写了一篇简短的文章来总结这些观点，这样你们就不必回头去听两年的节目或阅读两年的内容了。这篇文章的标题是《进步的幻觉：心理治疗是如何迷失方向的》。
Way. How market forces are shaping the practice and the future of psychotherapy. The field of psychotherapy faces an identity and a purpose crisis in the era of market-driven healthcare. As managed care, pharmaceutical dominance, and the biomedical model reshape mental health treatment, psychotherapy's traditional foundations, which are depth, nuance, and the therapeutic relationship are being displaced by the imperatives of cost and containment, standardization, and mass reproducibility. And this shift reflects the ascendancy of a neoliberal cultural ideology reducing the complexity of human suffering to decontextualize symptoms to be efficiently eliminated, not a meaningful experience to be explored and transformed. The symptom is the separate thing that we can just get rid of, but it doesn't link back
市场力量如何塑造心理治疗的实践与未来。在市场驱动的医疗保健时代，心理治疗领域正面临着身份和目的的危机。随着管理式医疗、制药业的统治地位以及生物医学模式重塑心理健康治疗，心理治疗的传统基础——即深度、细微差别和治疗关系——正被成本控制、标准化和大规模可复制性的要求所取代。这种转变反映了新自由主义文化意识形态的抬头，它将人类痛苦的复杂性简化为可以被高效消除的去语境化症状，而不是需要探索和转化的有意义的体验。症状被视为一种可以被轻易剔除的独立事物，但它并没有关联到
to a piece of a larger self or a piece of a larger society that needs to be examined and brought back into equilibrium. In Constructing the Self, Constructing America, cultural historian Philip Cushman argues that this psychotherapy crisis stems from a shift in notions of the self and therapy's aims. Individual identity and psychological health are shaped by cultural and economic and political forces, not a universal ideal. The rise of neoliberal capitalism and consumerism birthed an empty self plagued by this inner lack, pursuing fulfillment through goods and experiences and attainments, and insecurity about an inadequacy about falling behind in life's competitive race, a focus on appearances instead of internalized development. Mainstream
一个更大的自我或一个需要被审视并恢复平衡的更广阔的社会。在《构建自我，构建美国》一书中，文化历史学家菲利普·库什曼认为，这种心理治疗危机源于自我观念和治疗目标的变化。个人身份和心理健康是由文化、经济和政治力量塑造的，而非某种普遍的理想。新自由主义资本主义和消费主义的兴起催生了一个被内在匮乏感所困扰的“空虚自我”，人们通过商品、体验和成就来追求满足感，并因在生活的竞争赛道中落后而感到不安和自卑，从而将焦点转向了外表而非内在的发展。主流
psychotherapy largely reinforces this alienated individualistic and self-construction. Cognitive behavioral therapy and manualized treatment focus narrowly on maladaptive thoughts and behaviors without examining social, political, and existential contexts. Packaging therapy into standardized modules strips away relational essence for managed care's needs. Therapists become technicians, reinforcing a decontextualized view locating problems solely in the individual, overlooking unjust social conditions shaping the lives and the psyche of the individual. And central is the biomedical model's hegemony, viewing psychological structure as brain diseases treated pharmacologically, a seductive but
心理治疗在很大程度上强化了这种异化的个人主义和自我构建。认知行为疗法和手册化治疗狭隘地关注适应不良的思想和行为，而没有审视社会、政治和存在主义背景。将治疗打包成标准化的模块，剥离了管理式医疗需求下的关系本质。治疗师变成了技术员，强化了一种去语境化的观点，将问题完全归咎于个人，忽视了塑造个人生活和心理的不公正社会条件。核心在于生物医学模式的霸权，它将心理结构视为可以通过药物治疗的脑部疾病，这是一种诱人但
illusory promise. And we've had a big re-examining of all of the research that got us there as being something that was kind of a faulty foundation. Look up the STAR-D study if you're not familiar. The antidepressant use has massively grown despite the efficacy and the doubts about safety. And I'm not against all psychopharm. Don't send me an email. I don't think it's where you start. I think it's where you get to when you have an endogenous depression that will not change even after you have changed the environment. And this model of psychopharm and the biomedical model, it individualizes and medicalizes distress despite research that links depression to life pain, like poverty and unemployment and trauma and isolation and things that we could fix, arguably for a lot less money than we spend to have profit-seeking streams where drugs are developed or drugs are pushed. Digital technology furthers the need towards this disembodied technocratic mental health care to be
虚幻的承诺。我们已经对所有导致这一现状的研究进行了大规模的重新审视，发现其基础存在缺陷。如果你不熟悉，可以查阅一下STAR-D研究。尽管对抗抑郁药的疗效和安全性存在质疑，但其使用量却大幅增长。我并不是反对所有的精神药物，别给我发邮件。我不认为这是治疗的起点。我认为只有当你患有内源性抑郁症，即使在改变环境后仍无法改善时，才应该考虑药物。这种精神药物和生物医学模式将痛苦个人化和医疗化，尽管研究表明抑郁症与贫困、失业、创伤和孤立等生活痛苦有关，而这些问题我们本可以通过比投入利润驱动的药物开发和推广更少的资金来解决。数字技术进一步推动了这种去身体化的技术官僚式心理健康护理成为
the norm. Online therapy platforms and apps expand access, but they risk reducing therapy to scripted interactions and gamified inputs, not a genuine embodied attitude at meaning making. In his book Getting Loose, Lifestyle Consumption in the 1970s, sociologist Sam Binkley examines how the social transformations of the 1970s, driven by the rise of neoliberalism and consumer culture, profoundly reshaped notions of selfhood and the goals of therapeutic practice. Binkley argues that the dominant therapeutic model that emerged during this period, one that was centered on the purist, the pursuit of personal growth, self-actualization, and the loosening of the self from traditional constraints, you know, mainly aesthetic ones like, you know,
常态。在线治疗平台和应用程序扩大了获取渠道，但它们有将治疗简化为脚本化互动和游戏化输入的风险，而非一种真正体现意义构建的具身态度。社会学家萨姆·宾克利在他的著作《变得松散：1970年代的生活方式消费》中，探讨了由新自由主义和消费文化兴起所驱动的1970年代社会变革如何深刻地重塑了自我观念和治疗实践的目标。宾克利认为，这一时期出现的占主导地位的治疗模式，即以个人成长、自我实现以及将自我从传统束缚（主要是审美上的，比如，你知道，
marriage or the suburbs, unwittingly aligned itself with a neoliberal agenda that cast individuals as enterprising consumers responsible for their own fulfillment and well-being. So that hippie idea of being your own person and breaking the mold, Binkley's hypothesizing that that lined up really well with the neoliberal consumption idea that you are what you buy. And so instead of really changing themselves, they learned to express themselves through consumption dependent on the same couple monopolies. And so the movement was sort of hollow. So while ostensibly, and liberatory, this getting loose ethos ultimately reinforced atomization and alienation of the self under late capitalism. And by locating the source and the solution to psychological distress solely
婚姻或郊区生活）中解放出来为中心，无意中与新自由主义议程保持了一致，该议程将个人视为对自己满足感和幸福负责的进取型消费者。所以，那种“做你自己”并打破常规的嬉皮士思想，宾克利推测这与新自由主义的消费理念非常吻合，即“你买什么，你就是什么”。因此，他们并没有真正改变自己，而是学会了通过依赖同样的几家垄断企业来进行自我表达。所以这场运动在某种程度上是空洞的。因此，尽管表面上是解放性的，但这种“变得松散”的思潮最终强化了晚期资本主义下自我的原子化和异化。通过将心理痛苦的根源和解决方案完全定位
within the individual psyche, it obscured the broader social, economic, and political forces shaping mental health. So in doing so, it inadvertently contributed to the very conditions of getting loose. This pervasive sense of being unmoored, fragmented, adrift, that initially the idea of getting loose or, you know, tuning in, turning on, dropping out, getting out of the societal consumption was supposed to solve, ultimately it made them worse and hurt our ability to connect and have community and meaning. So Binkley's analysis, it offers a powerful lens for understanding the current crisis of psychotherapy. It suggests that the field increasingly embraces decontextualized technocratic approaches to treatment, not nearly not only like to
在个人心理内部，它掩盖了塑造心理健康的更广泛的社会、经济和政治力量。因此，它在无意中促成了“变得松散”的条件。这种普遍存在的漂泊感、碎片化和迷失感，最初是“变得松散”或“调频、开启、退出”、摆脱社会消费的理念试图解决的问题，最终却使情况变得更糟，并损害了我们建立联系、社区和意义的能力。因此，宾克利的分析为理解当前的心理治疗危机提供了一个强有力的视角。它表明，该领域越来越多地采用去语境化的技术官僚式治疗方法，不仅是因为
capitulate to market pressures but just as a logical extension of a therapeutic paradigm that has for a long time been complicit with the individualizing logic of neoliberalism um that your symptom is your symptom it is something that comes from something that you did, not, you know, a societal phenomenon or an expression of a greater pain or a process of something inside of your psyche that is out of relationship, just a symptom to be medicated and removed in a way that I would argue is not always possible as much of the time as the biomedical model tries to make it possible. So this imagining, reimagining, requires a move beyond the intrapsychic forces of traditional therapy to one that grapples with the social,
向市场压力屈服，而且是作为一种治疗范式的逻辑延伸，这种范式长期以来一直与新自由主义的个人化逻辑同流合污。即你的症状就是你的症状，它源于你所做的事情，而不是某种社会现象、更大痛苦的表达，或是你心理内部某种失去联系的过程。它仅仅是一个需要被药物化和移除的症状，而我敢说，这并不总是像生物医学模式试图实现的那样可行。因此，这种重构需要超越传统治疗的心理内部力量，转向一种能够处理社会、
political, and existential contexts of suffering. It means working to foster critical consciousness, relational vitality, and collective empowerment. Helping individuals to deconstruct the oppressive narratives and power structures that constrain their lives, and to tap into alternative sources of identity, belonging, and purpose. Such a transformation is not just a matter of therapeutic technique, but of a political and ethical commitment. It demands that therapists reimagine their work not merely as an alleviation of individual symptoms, but as a form of social and political action aiming at nurturing personal and collective liberation. And this means that
政治和存在主义痛苦背景的模式。这意味着要致力于培养批判性意识、关系活力和集体赋权。帮助个人解构限制其生活的压迫性叙事和权力结构，并挖掘身份、归属感和目的感的替代来源。这种转变不仅仅是治疗技术的问题，更是一种政治和伦理承诺。它要求治疗师重新构想他们的工作，不仅仅是缓解个人症状，而是作为一种旨在培育个人和集体解放的社会和政治行动。这意味着
cultivating spaces of collective healing and visioning and aligning ourselves with movements for social justice and systemic change. At stake is nothing less than the survival of the psychotherapy art itself. If current trends persist, our field will devolve into a character of itself, a hollow simulacrum of branded, efficient, quality-controlled treatment packages hawked by managed care. Therapists will be relegated to the role of glorified skills coaches and symptom suppression specialists, while the deep psychic wounds and social pathologies underlying the epidemic of mental distress will metastasize unchecked. And the choice before us is stark. Do we collude with a system that offers only the veneer of care while perpetuating the conditions of collective madness, or do we commit ourselves anew to the still revolutionary praxis of tending psyche,
培育集体治愈和愿景的空间，并将我们自己与社会正义和系统性变革的运动保持一致。这关系到心理治疗艺术本身的存亡。如果当前的趋势持续下去，我们的领域将退化为自身的一个特征，一个由管理式医疗兜售的品牌化、高效、质量受控的治疗套餐的空洞模拟物。治疗师将被降级为美化版的技能教练和症状抑制专家，而心理痛苦流行病背后的深层心理创伤和社会病理将不受控制地扩散。我们面临的选择是严峻的。我们是与一个只提供护理外表却延续集体疯狂条件的系统勾结，还是重新致力于那种仍然具有革命性的实践——即照料心理、
dialoguing with the unconscious, and giving a soul to psychotherapy? That was James Hillman in 1992 who said that. Ultimately, the struggle to reimagine therapy is inseparable from the struggle to build a more just, caring, and sustainable world. As the mental health toll of late capitalism continues to mount, the need for psychotherapy of liberation has never been more urgent. By rising to this challenge, we open up new possibilities for resilience, regeneration, and revolutionary love and beginning to create the world that we long for, even as we heal the world that we have. The shift in psychotherapy's identity and purpose can be traced back to broader
与无意识对话，并赋予心理治疗以灵魂？那是詹姆斯·希尔曼在1992年所说的话。归根结底，重构治疗的斗争与建立一个更公正、更有爱心和可持续的世界的斗争是不可分割的。随着晚期资本主义带来的心理健康代价不断增加，对解放性心理治疗的需求从未如此迫切。通过迎接这一挑战，我们为韧性、再生和革命性的爱开辟了新的可能性，并开始创造我们所渴望的世界，同时治愈我们所拥有的世界。心理治疗身份和目的的转变可以追溯到20世纪后期的更广泛的
socioeconomic transformations of the late 20th century, particularly the rise of neoliberalism under the Reagan and Thatcher administrations. Neoliberal ideology, with its emphasis on privatization, deregulation, and the supremacy of market forces, profoundly shaped the landscape of healthcare and academia in which psychotherapy is embedded. As healthcare became increasingly privatized and profit-driven, the provision of mental health services was subordinate to the logic of the market, and so the ascendancy of managed care organizations and private insurance companies created powerful new stakeholders who saw psychotherapy not as a healing art, but as a commodity to be standardized, packaged, and sold. Under this market-driven system, the value of therapy was reduced to its cost-effectiveness
社会经济转型，特别是里根和撒切尔政府时期新自由主义的兴起。新自由主义意识形态强调私有化、放松管制和市场力量的至高无上，深刻地塑造了心理治疗所处的医疗保健和学术环境。随着医疗保健日益私有化和以利润为导向，心理健康服务的提供从属于市场逻辑，因此，管理式医疗组织和私人保险公司的崛起创造了强大的新利益相关者，他们不将心理治疗视为一种治愈艺术，而将其视为一种可以标准化、打包和销售的商品。在这种市场驱动的体系下，治疗的价值被简化为成本效益
and its capacity to produce swift, measurable outcomes. Depth, nuance, and the exploration of meaning at the traditional heart of the therapeutic enterprise were casualties of this shift, and concurrent with these changes in healthcare and neoliberal restructuring of academia further marginalized psychotherapy's humanistic foundations. As universities increasingly embraced a corporate model, they became beholden to the same market imperatives of efficiency, standardization, and quantification. In this milieu, the kind of research and training that could sustain a rich, multifaceted understanding of the therapeutic process was devalued in favor
以及产生快速、可衡量结果的能力。深度、细微差别和对意义的探索——这些传统治疗事业的核心——成为了这一转变的牺牲品。与此同时，医疗保健领域的这些变化和学术界的新自由主义重组进一步边缘化了心理治疗的人文主义基础。随着大学越来越多地拥抱企业模式，它们变得受制于同样的效率、标准化和量化等市场要求。在这种环境下，那种能够维持对治疗过程丰富、多面理解的研究和培训被贬低，转而支持
of reductive, manualized approaches more amenable to the demands of the market. And the academic climate elevated a narrow cast of specialists, who often are pretty far removed from any sort of clinical practice, and no, working at the student counseling center one day a week as a supervisor is not a form of clinical practice that I mean, who were empowered to define the parameters of legitimate knowledge and practice in the field, beholden to the interest of managed care, the pharmaceutical industry and the biomedical establishment, you know, used these experts to cement hegemony of the medical model and sign-line any kind of alternative therapeutic paradigm. Even, especially
更符合市场需求的还原论、手册化方法。学术氛围抬高了一小撮专家，他们往往与任何临床实践相去甚远——不，每周在学生咨询中心做一天督导并不算是我所指的临床实践——他们被授权定义该领域合法知识和实践的参数，受制于管理式医疗、制药行业和生物医学机构的利益，你知道，利用这些专家来巩固医学模式的霸权，并将任何替代性的治疗范式边缘化。甚至，特别是
through sidelining research of anything that wouldn't be paid for by a drug company or wouldn't ultimately benefit the bottom line of somebody who could afford to do the millions of dollars of research. So when you tie psychotherapy to research, that's unethical unless you're going to research everything equally. When you're only going to research things that a certain group has a vested interest in, you can't call that an ethical study because that isn't the way that I understand ethics and psychology to function. Researcher William Davies has argued that this neoliberal transformation of psychotherapy reflects a broader disenchantment of politics by economics. By reducing the complexities of mental distress
通过将任何不会由制药公司支付或最终不会使那些有能力进行数百万美元研究的人受益的研究边缘化。所以，当你把心理治疗与研究挂钩时，除非你平等地研究所有事物，否则这是不道德的。当你只研究某些群体有既得利益的事物时，你不能称之为道德研究，因为那不是我理解的伦理和心理学运作的方式。研究员威廉·戴维斯认为，这种心理治疗的新自由主义转型反映了经济对政治更广泛的祛魅。通过将心理痛苦的复杂性
to quantifiable medical-wise entities, the field has become more complicit in the evisceration of human subjectivity under late capitalism. In place of a situated meaning-making self, we are left with a hollow figure of the homo economicus, you know, the rational, self-interested actor shorn of deeper psychological spiritual mooring. That is the economic man, which was one of the ways that people made fun of John Stuart Mill's theories later. The idea that the sole motivation that you could use to study economy was just that human beings were pleasure-seeking creatures that made rational market decisions to increase their financial power and that you could build an economic
简化为可量化的医学实体，该领域在晚期资本主义下对人类主体性的破坏变得更加同流合污。取而代之的是一个空洞的“经济人”形象，你知道，那个被剥离了更深层心理和精神支撑的、理性的、自私自利的行动者。这就是“经济人”，这是后来人们嘲笑约翰·斯图尔特·密尔理论的方式之一。这种观点认为，你可以用来研究经济的唯一动机就是人类是追求快乐的生物，他们做出理性的市场决策来增加财务权力，并且你可以建立一个依赖于此的经济
system that relied on that because that's true and that was all that we were. And when you follow that as an extension of economy to a politics or a psychology that is beholden to that kind of economy and political economy, you start to see those assumptions showing up in psychology in a way that is very scary and very anti-psychological and anti-empirical. Tragically, the public discourse around mental health has largely been corralled into this narrow market-friendly mold. Discussions of chemical imbalances, evidence-based treatment, and quick fixes abound, while more searching explorations of the psychospiritual malaise of our time are relegated to the margins. The result is a flattened and impoverished understanding of both the nature of psychological distress and the possibilities of therapeutic transformation. Psychotherapy's capitulation to market forces is thus not merely
体系，因为这是事实，而我们也不过如此。当你把这作为经济学的延伸应用到受制于那种经济和政治经济学的政治或心理学中时，你开始看到这些假设以一种非常可怕、非常反心理学和反经验的方式出现在心理学中。可悲的是，围绕心理健康的公共话语在很大程度上被圈定在这个狭隘的市场友好型模具中。关于化学失衡、循证治疗和快速修复的讨论比比皆是，而对我们这个时代心理精神不适的更深入探索却被边缘化了。结果是对心理痛苦的本质和治疗转化的可能性产生了一种扁平化和贫困化的理解。因此，心理治疗向市场力量的屈服不仅仅是
an abdication of its healing potential, but a betrayal of its emancipatory promise, the original promise of why we go to therapy, why therapy was created. By uncritically aligning yourself with the dominant ideology of the age, the field has become an instrument of social control rather than a catalyst for individual and collective liberation. If therapy is to reclaim its soul, it must begin by confronting this history and imagining alternatives beyond what the neoliberals can imagine. When you look at other scientific fields, like somebody like Noam Chomsky, you know, he does some political science stuff, but also he's a groundbreaking linguist in the cognitive sciences. And his work in the cognitive sciences has been accepted as canon, essentially.
对其治愈潜力的放弃，更是对其解放承诺的背叛——这是我们进行治疗、创建治疗的最初承诺。通过不加批判地与这个时代的统治意识形态保持一致，该领域已成为社会控制的工具，而不是个人和集体解放的催化剂。如果治疗要找回它的灵魂，它必须首先面对这段历史，并想象出新自由主义者无法想象的替代方案。当你观察其他科学领域时，比如像诺姆·乔姆斯基这样的人，你知道，他做了一些政治学研究，但他也是认知科学领域开创性的语言学家。他在认知科学方面的工作基本上已被接受为经典。
There's not very many people who think that it's wrong, even though there's a limited extent to which it can be empirically proven. It becomes the operating assumption of people just because it works when you plug it into the model and because intuitively they can rely on it to be a consistent phenomenon, even though we can't exactly prove his really big concepts, like the language acquisition device just has too many soft spots for it to be run through a randomized controlled trial, but it's still something that we think is real in that world of empiricism. Now, his theories of this deep grammatical structure and, you know, the way that we acquire language, those didn't come out of, you know, experiments or quantitative data analysis, but from deep intuitive engagement with the pattern of human language and thought, and then the empiricism of that subjectivity. Yet, while Chomsky's ideas are celebrated for their revolutionary implications,
没有多少人认为它是错的，尽管它在经验上能被证明的程度有限。它成为人们的操作假设，仅仅是因为当你把它代入模型时它有效，而且凭直觉他们可以依赖它成为一种一致的现象，尽管我们无法确切证明他那些非常宏大的概念，比如“语言习得装置”有太多的软肋，无法通过随机对照试验来验证，但它仍然是我们认为在那个经验主义世界中真实存在的东西。现在，他关于这种深层语法结构以及我们习得语言方式的理论，并不是来自实验或定量数据分析，而是来自对人类语言和思维模式的深刻直觉参与，以及那种主体性的经验主义。然而，尽管乔姆斯基的思想因其革命性的意义而受到赞誉，
similar approaches in the field of psychotherapy are often met with skepticism or outright dismissal. The work of Carl Jung, for example, which posits the existence of a collective unconscious and universal archetypes shaping human experience is often relegated to the realm of pseudoscience or mysticism by the mainstream psychological establishment. And this double standard reflects a deep-seated insecurity within the academic and medical psychology about engaging with phenomena that resist easy quantification or empirical verification. There is a pervasive fear of straying too far from the narrow confines of what can be measured, controlled, and reduced
心理治疗领域中类似的方法却经常遭到怀疑或直接否定。例如，卡尔·荣格的工作，他提出了塑造人类经验的集体无意识和普遍原型的存在，经常被主流心理学界贬低为伪科学或神秘主义。这种双重标准反映了学术和医学心理学在处理那些拒绝简单量化或经验验证的现象时，内心深处存在着一种深深的不安全感。人们普遍害怕偏离那些可以被测量、控制和还原的狭隘范围
to a standardized formula. And ironically, this insecurity persists even as cutting-edge research in fields like neuroscience and cognitive psychology increasingly validate many of Jung's once-marginalized ideas. Concepts like implicit memory, event-related potentials, predictive processing, they bear a striking resemblance to Jung's ideas of the unconscious mind, almost like somebody took all of the work that other people did with those theories and then said that's pseudoscience and came up with a new name for an empirical part, observable part, of the truth of those theories without being able to connect the dots. And here's the thing, man, I don't think they did it to enrich themselves. I don't know that anyone becomes a PhD scientist to enrich themselves, which to me is scarier. What are they getting out of this, you know?
到某种标准化公式的程度。具有讽刺意味的是，即使神经科学和认知心理学等领域的前沿研究越来越多地验证了荣格许多曾经被边缘化的思想，这种不安全感依然存在。诸如内隐记忆、事件相关电位、预测处理等概念，与荣格关于无意识心灵的思想有着惊人的相似之处，就像有人拿走了其他人用这些理论所做的一切工作，然后说那是伪科学，并为这些理论中经验性的、可观察的部分起了一个新名字，却无法将它们联系起来。事情是这样的，伙计，我不认为他们这样做是为了中饱私囊。我不知道是否有人会为了中饱私囊而成为博士科学家，这对我来说更可怕。他们从中得到了什么，你知道吗？
An ego stroke? I mean, that's sadder than if you were laughing all the way to the bank so you know things like the myers-briggs and i've got an article about this if you want more detail but things like the mbti that you know yung didn't make the mbti but he made the assumptions that made the first three letters and then myers and briggs made up the last two but he did the groundwork for that and rather than acknowledge you know where these new theories about thought type and preference and you know diametrically opposed types of cognition you know that we can now see on qeg despite talking about how those overlap with these things, that we're finally having technologies
一种自我满足？我的意思是，这比你数钱数到手软还要悲哀，所以你知道像迈尔斯-布里格斯类型指标（MBTI）这样的东西——如果你想要更多细节，我有一篇文章专门讲这个——你知道荣格并没有制造MBTI，但他做出了构成前三个字母的假设，然后迈尔斯和布里格斯编造了最后两个，但他为之奠定了基础。与其承认你知道这些关于思维类型和偏好以及你知道的截然相反的认知类型的新理论，你知道我们现在可以在QEG（定量脑电图）上看到，尽管谈论它们如何与这些事物重叠，我们终于有了技术
caught up for us to have the empirical ability to validate a lot of the things that we used to only have to hypothesize about intuitively, you know, the way science has always worked. Now that's rejected, you know. The psychological establishment repackages these ideas in more palatable scientific terminology, but they don't give credit. They don't cite their sources. And a lot of the time, it's because they don't know the history well enough to understand what their sources are, which again, I'm not, this may sound conspiratorial, it's not supposed to be. The fact that it is done out of ignorance instead of malice, I think is scarier and should scare
让我们有经验能力去验证很多我们过去只能凭直觉假设的东西，你知道，科学一直以来的运作方式。现在这被拒绝了，你知道。心理学界用更悦耳的科学术语重新包装了这些思想，但他们不给予认可。他们不引用来源。很多时候，这是因为他们对历史了解不够，无法理解他们的来源是什么，这再次说明，这听起来可能像阴谋论，但它本不该如此。事实上，它是出于无知而不是恶意，我认为这更可怕，而且应该让你
you more. They don't know the history of the profession, and they don't know the history of the flow of ideas within it. This aversion to intuition and subjective experience is hardly unique to psychotherapy. Across the sciences, there's a widespread mistrust of knowledge that cannot be reduced to quantifiable data points and mathematical models. You know, however, some of the most transformative scientific advancements have emerged from precisely this kind of intuitive imaginative thinking. Albert Einstein's theory of relativity, for instance, emerged not from empirical data, but from a thought experiment, an act of imagination. The physicist David Bohm's innovative theories about the implicate order of the universe
感到更害怕。他们不知道这个职业的历史，也不知道思想在其中流动的历史。这种对直觉和主观经验的厌恶在心理治疗中绝非独有。在整个科学界，人们普遍不信任那些无法简化为可量化数据点和数学模型的知识。然而，一些最具变革性的科学进步恰恰来自这种直觉性的、富有想象力的思维。例如，阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦的相对论，并非来自经验数据，而是来自一个思想实验，一种想象力的行为。物理学家大卫·玻姆关于宇宙隐秩序的创新理论
were rooted in a profoundly intuitive understanding of reality. And the mathematician Ramunja attributed his brilliant insights to visions from a hindu goddess um a claim that might be dismissed as delusional in a clinical context but it's celebrated as an expression of his unique genius and a lot of times it's because these mystical or spiritual experience function as unconscious semi-conscious maybe conscious metaphors you know there are containers there are the way that language contains the part of the brain that we cannot directly experience. That is what the unconscious is, and that's why to pretend that it doesn't exist is so silly, because for anyone who gets that, you're going to see those containers everywhere.
植根于对现实深刻的直觉理解。数学家拉马努金将他辉煌的洞见归功于印度女神的启示，这在临床背景下可能会被斥为妄想，但它却被赞誉为他独特天才的表达。很多时候，这是因为这些神秘或精神体验起到了无意识的、半意识的、也许是意识的隐喻作用，你知道，它们是容器，是语言包含大脑中我们无法直接体验的那部分的方式。这就是无意识，这就是为什么假装它不存在是如此愚蠢，因为对于任何理解这一点的人来说，你会到处看到这些容器。
Psychotherapy should not abandon empirical rigor or the scientific method, but rather it should expand its understanding of what constitutes meaningful evidence. By making room for insights, subjective experiences, and phenomenological explorations alongside quantitative data and experimental findings, the field can develop a richer, more multidimensional understanding of the human mind in the process of psychological transformation. This expansive and integrative approach is necessary for psychotherapy to rise to the challenges of our time. The crisis of meaning and authenticity in an increasingly fragmented world, the epidemic of mental health, mental, you know, illness and addiction, and the collective traumas of social oppression and ecological devastation. Only by
心理治疗不应放弃经验严谨性或科学方法，而应扩大其对何为有意义证据的理解。通过在定量数据和实验结果之外，为洞见、主观体验和现象学探索留出空间，该领域可以对人类心灵和心理转化过程发展出一种更丰富、更多维的理解。这种包容性和整合性的方法对于心理治疗迎接我们时代的挑战是必要的。在一个日益碎片化的世界中，意义和真实性的危机，心理健康、精神疾病和成瘾的流行，以及社会压迫和生态破坏带来的集体创伤。只有通过
honoring the full spectrum of human knowledge and experience can we hope to catalyze the kind of deep lasting change that our world so desperately needs. And I view, you know, psychotherapy as a path to get there. I view the healing of trauma collectively as a way that we must get where we need to go. And it's a particular vexation of mine that the academic psychology is so hostile to the vague but perennial ideas about the unconscious that Jung and others posited. You know, now neurology is revalidating Jungian concepts under different names. While the QEG brain maps, you know, I had mentioned are also, a whole lot of evidence, if you have the eyes to see it, that a lot of Jungian phenomenology wasn't wrong. But they still can't admit that, even when they repackage the same ideas and publish them in things like The Lancet, you'll still find things about Jungian ideas about dreams or something being pseudoscience, even though they explain these realities, that are now verifiable. Academia seems to believe that its publications have innate
尊重人类知识和经验的全谱，我们才有希望催化我们世界迫切需要的深层、持久的变革。我将心理治疗视为实现这一目标的途径。我将集体治愈创伤视为我们必须到达目的地的方式。学术心理学对荣格等人提出的关于无意识的模糊但永恒的思想如此敌视，这让我感到特别烦恼。你知道，现在神经学正在用不同的名字重新验证荣格的概念。虽然我提到的QEG脑图，也有大量的证据，如果你有眼光去看的话，证明许多荣格现象学并没有错。但他们仍然无法承认这一点，即使当他们重新包装相同的思想并将其发表在《柳叶刀》等期刊上时，你仍然会发现关于荣格梦境思想等是伪科学的内容，尽管它们解释了这些现在可以验证的现实。学术界似乎相信，只要执行了心理学研究的适当仪式，其出版物就具有内在的
efficacy and ethics as long as the proper rituals of psychological research are enacted. If you cite your sources, review recent literature in your echo chamber, disclose your financial interests, and then profess ignorance of your profession's history and the unethical systems funding your existence, then you're doing research correctly. But the system that is paying for your entire existence, like that isn't a conflict of interest. That's just the way the business works, right? And why are you pointing this out to me? I didn't even know that, so it's not my fault, you know, say the people working in that system. This is considered perfectly rational as long as we don't think too deeply about it. A lot of the people who have either sent me an email or who have asked me
效力和伦理。如果你引用你的来源，在你的回声室里回顾最近的文献，披露你的经济利益，然后声称对你职业的历史和你赖以生存的不道德系统一无所知，那么你就是在正确地进行研究。但那个为你整个生存买单的系统，那不是利益冲突。那只是生意运作的方式，对吧？为什么你要向我指出这一点？我甚至不知道，所以这不是我的错，你知道，在那个系统里工作的人会这样说。只要我们不深入思考，这就被认为是完全理性的。很多给我发过邮件或者在会议上问过我
what I think about this at a conference or something and I've talked to them, what they'll say is like, I don't get into any of that because I do academic psychology or I do medical psychology. Well, I think that understanding how humans and cultures are uniquely traumatized and motivated is part of your job, even if you're just going to run a university or just going to make decisions for a hospital or an insurance company about how an entire state gets to practice healthcare. Yeah, those are relevant details that you should know as a part of psychology. So I guess I don't know what academic or medical psychology means in this context, other than I publish papers for a living. And the attitude seems to be, let's just keep handing out CBT and drugs for another 50 years that are rational and evidence-based, of course, and we'll see how much
对此有何看法的人，我与他们交谈过，他们会说，我不参与任何这些，因为我做的是学术心理学或医学心理学。好吧，我认为理解人类和文化是如何被独特地创伤和激励的，是你工作的一部分，即使你只是要经营一所大学，或者只是要为医院或保险公司决定整个州如何进行医疗保健。是的，这些是你作为心理学的一部分应该知道的相关细节。所以我猜我不知道在这种背景下学术或医学心理学意味着什么，除了我以发表论文为生。而且态度似乎是，让我们继续分发CBT和药物再过50年，当然，它们是理性的和循证的，我们会看看情况会变得
worse things get then. We can go back and we can see when we started to do these things. We can see what mental health outcomes were after we started to do them. So why can't we see what we are doing? You know, no wonder outcomes in the replication crisis from all of these studies, like the STAR-D study, again, look that one up, worsen every year. And even as healthcare is ostensibly more rational and more empirical and more evidence-based than it has ever been, outcomes are worse. So why? And my answer, again, is not conspiracies and science isn't real. It's that what you're doing is not science. You're just calling it that. And you've got little props
多糟糕。我们可以回头看看我们什么时候开始做这些事情。我们可以看到我们开始做这些事情后的心理健康结果。那么为什么我们不能看到我们正在做什么呢？你知道，难怪所有这些研究（再次强调，查阅一下STAR-D研究）的复制危机中的结果每年都在恶化。即使医疗保健表面上比以往任何时候都更理性、更经验化、更循证，结果却更糟。那么为什么呢？我的回答再次不是阴谋论，也不是科学不是真的。而是你所做的不是科学。你只是称之为科学。而且你有一些小道具
that you hold up to pretend that it is. You know, academia has created a model of reality called science, and they've applied it so single-mindedly that they no longer care if the outcomes mirror those of the real world. That science was meant to serve. It was meant to be an extrapolation of the real in order to divine its realities with a study. You know, academic and medical psychology have created a copy of the world, and they interact with it pretending it reflects reality while it fundamentally cannot due to the material incentives that drive their system. And what they don't want to see about how those material incentives drive our reality, economically and politically. We've created a scientific model that was meant to reflect reality, but then we have mistaken it
你举着它们来假装它是科学。你知道，学术界创造了一个名为“科学”的现实模型，并且他们如此专注地应用它，以至于他们不再关心结果是否反映了现实世界。科学本应服务于现实。它本应是对现实的推演，以便通过研究来推断其真实性。你知道，学术和医学心理学创造了一个世界的副本，他们与它互动，假装它反映了现实，而由于驱动其系统的物质激励，它从根本上无法做到这一点。他们不想看到这些物质激励如何在经济和政治上驱动我们的现实。我们创造了一个本应反映现实的科学模型，但随后我们却把它误认为
for reality itself. And we are reaching in vain to try and move something that's on the other side of a mirror instead of engaging with what's actually real. How do we not see that hyper-rationalism is just another form of religion, even as we tried to replace religion with it? This concept of psychology is not only an imaginary model. The academic and the medical, biomedical conception of psychology is not only an imaginary model. The academic and the medical biomedical conception of psychology is not only just not real, it's at war with the real because it cuts us off from truly logical evidence-based pathways that we could pursue. One of the things that I heard all the time in the hospital was, yeah, what you're doing works and that's a good idea and it sounds right,
是现实本身。我们徒劳地试图移动镜子另一边的东西，而不是与真正真实的东西互动。我们怎么会看不出超理性主义只是宗教的另一种形式，即使我们试图用它来取代宗教？这种心理学概念不仅是一个想象的模型。学术和医学、生物医学的心理学概念不仅是一个想象的模型。学术和医学生物医学的心理学概念不仅是不真实的，它还与现实处于战争状态，因为它切断了我们本可以追求的真正合乎逻辑的、循证的途径。我在医院里经常听到的一件事是，是的，你所做的是有效的，那是个好主意，听起来也不错，
but it isn't evidence-based. Well, didn't I just start a study there? Didn't I just do something 50 times and it worked? I mean, do you know the scientific method? We must choose entirely between the object and its reflection, the god and the idol. We must decide if we want the uncertainty of real science or the certainty of the imaginary sandbox that we pretend is science now. Adherence to the simulacrum in search of effective trauma and mental illness treatment, it has
但它不是循证的。好吧，我不是刚在那里开始了一项研究吗？我不是刚做了50次并且它奏效了吗？我的意思是，你知道科学方法吗？我们必须在客体及其反射、上帝和偶像之间做出完全的选择。我们必须决定我们是想要真正科学的不确定性，还是我们现在假装是科学的想象沙盒的确定性。为了寻找有效的创伤和精神疾病治疗而坚持这种模拟物，它已经
become a cultural trauma response that we even bother to adhere to it at all. It is an addiction to the familiar and the broken, over the effective but the frightening. This is no different than a cult or a conspiracy theory. A major pillar of our civilization would whether perpetuate what is familiar and broken, then dare to change, and such methodological fundamentalism is indistinguishable from religious devotion. We have a group so committed to their notion of the rational that they've decided reason and empiricism should no longer be beholden to reality. How is our approach to clinical psychology research any different than a belief in magic at this point? The deflections of those controlling mainstream psychology sound,
成为一种文化创伤反应，以至于我们甚至费心去坚持它。这是一种对熟悉和破碎事物的沉迷，而不是对有效但令人恐惧的事物的追求。这与邪教或阴谋论没有什么不同。我们文明的一个主要支柱是宁愿延续那些熟悉但破碎的东西，也不敢改变，这种方法论上的原教旨主义与宗教虔诚无异。我们有一群人如此致力于他们对理性的概念，以至于他们决定理性和经验主义不再需要受制于现实。在这一点上，我们对待临床心理学研究的方法与相信魔法有什么不同？那些控制主流心理学的人的推诿听起来，
they should sound familiar. They are the same ego defenses that you would identify in a traumatized therapy patient. Academic psychology's reasoning is starting to resemble what it would diagnose if it came in as a patient to itself as a personality disorder. It's not me doing it wrong, even though I'm just not getting the results that I want every time I do the thing. It's the world that's wrong because it's not enabling my preferred approach. Effective practitioners must be cheating or deluded. The people who are getting good results out there, outside of the hospital, they must be crazy.
它们听起来应该很熟悉。它们是你会在一个受创伤的治疗病人身上识别出的相同的自我防御机制。学术心理学的推理开始类似于如果它作为一个病人来到自己面前，它会诊断出的那种人格障碍。不是我做错了，尽管我每次做这件事时都没有得到我想要的结果。是世界错了，因为它没有启用我首选的方法。有效的从业者一定是作弊或被误导了。那些在医院外取得良好结果的人，他们一定是疯了。
Those who do it like me are right, though none of us get any good results. Our results are bad, but our methods are right, and the methods are right because they yield the good results, except the methods that are right aren't getting us the good results, so we better just keep doing it our way harder. You know, anyone who's talking out of their mouth in both directions like that, you would have no issue slapping with some kind of diagnosis and therapy, but when it's them doing it collectively at a conference, it's like, oh, a big issue. That's a great point. And we need to take a long look in the mirror and have a long conversation about that. Anyone who's ever said, take a long look in the mirror, or we all just need to sit down as a society and have a long conversation,
那些像我一样做的人是对的，尽管我们中没有人得到任何好的结果。我们的结果很糟糕，但我们的方法是对的，而且方法是对的，因为它们产生了好的结果，除了那些正确的方法并没有给我们带来好的结果，所以我们最好还是更努力地坚持我们的方式。你知道，任何像那样两面说话的人，你对他贴上某种诊断和治疗标签都不会有任何问题，但当他们集体在会议上这样做时，就像是，哦，一个大问题。这是一个很好的观点。我们需要照照镜子，就此进行长时间的谈话。任何说过“照照镜子”或者“我们社会只需要坐下来进行长时间的谈话”的人，
they don't want to solve a problem. Because when you're saying that, what you're looking at is the most obvious problem and the most obvious solution in the world, and you don't want to see it. So you want to muddy the water to pretend that it's deep. And I guarantee you, if you talk to people in that world about this, that's what you'll get, is that if it was so simple, it would have been fixed already. So let's make it worse by making it more complicated. Now, when I did that Healing the Modern Soul series, you know, I said that I believe that psychology's role is part of its job is to have a functional and coherent definition of self, what self means when we're talking to another person, what we think that person is.
他们并不想解决问题。因为当你这么说的时候，你所看到的是世界上最明显的问题和最明显的解决方案，而你不想看到它。所以你想把水搅浑，假装它很深。我向你保证，如果你在那个世界里和人们谈论这件事，你得到的就会是：如果它那么简单，早就解决了。所以让我们通过让它变得更复杂来让情况变得更糟。现在，当我做那个《治愈现代灵魂》系列时，你知道，我说过我相信心理学的作用是，它工作的一部分是拥有一个功能性和连贯的自我定义，当我们与另一个人交谈时，自我意味着什么，我们认为那个人是什么。
And because of that, clinical psychology is always going to be inherently political. So, you know, material forces will always seek to define and control what psychology can be. So if you're saying, well, it can't be political or research isn't political, then you just don't understand how it works, because it is. It's like the people who, and you know, I don't really get into politics much on here, but it was like, I don't go to football games either, I'm just not a football fan. I'm not a football guy. But when you had somebody kneeling to protest what they wanted on a football game, and then people were yelling on my LinkedIn, like, football is not political. Keep your politics out of my football. Well, I mean, one of the last three times I went to a football game, they had American flag fireworks and jets flying over the stadium and a salute to the troops. And
正因如此，临床心理学注定是内在政治化的。所以，你知道，物质力量总会试图定义和控制心理学能成为什么。因此，如果你说，嗯，它不可能是政治性的，或者研究不是政治性的，那你只是不了解它是如何运作的，因为它确实如此。这就像那些人，你知道，我在这里不太谈论政治，但这就像，我也不去看橄榄球比赛，我不是橄榄球迷。我不是那种喜欢橄榄球的人。但当有人在橄榄球比赛中下跪抗议他们想要的东西时，人们在我的领英上大喊大叫，说橄榄球不是政治性的。别把你的政治带进我的橄榄球。好吧，我的意思是，我最后三次去看橄榄球比赛中的一次，他们有美国国旗烟花、喷气式飞机飞过体育场，还有向军队致敬的仪式。而且
I'm not saying that that's wrong or I disagree with it. I'm saying that is politics. So if you're saying you don't want football to be political, then I think you just don't notice where politics are when you like them. And when people say that psychology is not political, or they say that psychology doesn't have anything to do with economy or these other things. Well, I'm not an expert in that. I just want to study this little thing. What they're saying is, I don't want to see it. They're not making a case that it's not there. And if you want to hang out in this profession, and you also want to make a case that you don't see the forces that move it, then I think that you should get out. Because
我并不是说那是错的，或者我不同意它。我是在说，那就是政治。所以如果你说你不想让橄榄球变得政治化，那么我想你只是没有注意到当你喜欢政治时，它们在哪里。当人们说心理学不是政治性的，或者他们说心理学与经济或其他这些事情无关时。好吧，我不是那方面的专家。我只是想研究这个小东西。他们真正想说的是，我不想看到它。他们并没有证明它不存在。如果你想在这个行业混下去，同时又想证明你看不到推动它的力量，那么我认为你应该离开。因为
what are you doing? You're not in it anyway. You're just saying you want to play. And some of this drive to ignore these things is because people want to play. They want to have a little sandbox that they get to pretend is doing something real and none of the controls are hooked up to anything because it's a toy. And I think that when you look at why a lot of these things got worse, I mean, yeah, there's shareholders and people laughing all the way to the bank. Generally, those people are not the psychologists. Sometimes they are, but a lot of the time, it's these highly academic people that have had any sort of agency withheld from them for so long. You have to jump through so many hoops. You have to have so much debt. You have to shave all the ideas off your vision. You have to do what
你在做什么？反正你也不在其中。你只是说你想玩。这种忽视这些事情的动力，部分是因为人们想玩。他们想要一个可以假装在做实事的小沙盒，而且没有任何控制装置连接到任何东西，因为它只是一个玩具。我认为，当你审视为什么很多事情变得更糟时，我的意思是，是的，有股东和那些一路笑到银行的人。通常，这些人不是心理学家。有时他们是，但很多时候，是这些高度学术化的人，他们被剥夺了任何形式的代理权太久了。你必须经历太多的考验。你必须背负太多的债务。你必须削减掉你愿景中所有的想法。你必须做
your advisor wants. You have to do something that's being researched right now. You can't do your own. And then finally, you get to do it, and there's this sunk cost fallacy of I have to defend this system that's broken by just being like, well, I don't know anything about all of that. I just have been waiting for 15 years for the ability to teach in this hospital and be seen as the expert who knows everything. So please don't bring up things that I don't know. You know, there's like that attitude, which to me is just sadder. But end of the day, the culture is very sick and it's going to be resistant to a psychology that would challenge its unhealthy games with a coherent sense of self, because like any patient, our culture wants to deflect unhealthy games with a coherent sense of self, because like any patient, our culture wants to deflect and it fears the first step of healing, which is admitting you have a problem. And that sickness strokes the right egos and it lines the right pockets of a societal scale version of, you know, you go look at Eric Burns, the games we play, those interpersonal games that he brings up in that book. Our current psychological paradigm requires a hierarchy with one group playing sick emotional
你的导师想让你做的事。你必须做一些目前正在研究的事情。你不能做你自己的。最后，你终于可以做了，却陷入了沉没成本谬误，即我必须通过说“嗯，我对所有这些一无所知”来捍卫这个破碎的系统。我只是等了15年才获得在这家医院教学的能力，并被视为无所不知的专家。所以请不要提出我不知道的事情。你知道，有那种态度，对我来说更可悲。但归根结底，这种文化病得很重，它会抵制一种能以连贯的自我意识挑战其不健康游戏的心理学，因为像任何病人一样，我们的文化想要转移注意力，它害怕治愈的第一步，那就是承认你有问题。这种疾病迎合了正确的自我，并填满了社会规模版本的口袋，你知道，你去看看埃里克·伯恩的《我们玩的游戏》，他在那本书中提到的那些人际游戏。我们当前的心理学范式需要一个等级制度，其中一组扮演生病的、被看不起的情感
child who gets talked down to, and then the other hyper-rational all-knowing parent that's going to tell you what to do. And that may be inevitable in some medical settings, you know, when people have different levels of functioning or different levels of training are required to do the thing, you're going to have never a completely equal relationship. But it's too transactional. And us making it more transactional is making other people more money. And so that has been encouraged in a way that is at war with the authentic and the collaborative elements that psychotherapy should have. And I've argued before that one of the key challenges facing psychotherapy today is the, you know, fragmentation and the complex study of just modern identity. Because, you know,
孩子，然后另一组是超级理性的、无所不知的家长，要告诉你该怎么做。在某些医疗环境中，这可能是不可避免的，你知道，当人们有不同程度的功能或需要不同程度的培训来做这件事时，你永远不会有完全平等的关系。但它太交易化了。我们让它变得更加交易化，是在让其他人赚更多的钱。因此，这种方式受到鼓励，与心理治疗应该具备的真实和协作元素背道而驰。我之前曾争辩说，当今心理治疗面临的关键挑战之一是，你知道，现代身份的碎片化和复杂研究。因为，你知道，
when I say it in these kind of words, it's really to get a lot of people on the same side, because usually people who wouldn't normally agree with each other will hear me say something like this, or they'll read an article, and they'll say, oh my god, that's right, I've worked somewhere and what we did was stupid and it didn't make any sense. But then when we get into diagnosing it and explaining what a solution would be, they would say, oh no, that's communism, or oh no, that's right-wing, or oh no, that's, you know, there's an association that they have with any of the language. And I think language being that divisive is part of the postmodern. I mean, that we have this globalized digitally connected world where we're constantly navigating a myriad of roles, relationships, and cultural contexts that each have their own expectations and demands. I mean,
当我用这些词来说时，实际上是为了让很多人站在同一边，因为通常那些平时不会互相认同的人会听到我说这样的话，或者他们会读到一篇文章，他们会说，天哪，那是对的，我在某个地方工作过，我们所做的是愚蠢的，没有任何意义。但当我们开始诊断它并解释解决方案是什么时，他们会说，哦不，那是共产主义，或者哦不，那是右翼，或者哦不，那是，你知道，他们对任何语言都有联想。我认为语言如此具有分裂性是后现代的一部分。我的意思是，我们拥有这个全球化、数字化连接的世界，我们不断地在无数的角色、关系和文化背景中穿梭，每一个都有自己的期望和要求。我的意思是，
you have to play two roles. You may have to play one thing when you're talking to your boss, another thing when you're talking to a customer, and then hopefully you remember who you are when you get home. We wear a lot of persona, and the reality of the digital world and the modern world means that we have to wear a whole lot more, which makes remembering, you know, defining something like a itself a lot harder than it used to be. And it's arguably one of the hardest parts of our humanity, I would say. So even though most people would agree that our system is bad, the fragmentary nature of the postmodern has left us looking through a kaleidoscope and we're unable to agree on hero or villain, cause or solution, you know, framework
你必须扮演两个角色。当你和老板说话时，你可能必须扮演一种角色，当你和客户说话时，扮演另一种角色，然后希望当你回家时，你还记得你是谁。我们戴着很多面具，数字世界和现代世界的现实意味着我们必须戴上更多，这使得记住，你知道，定义像自我这样的东西比过去困难得多。我认为这可以说是我们人性中最困难的部分之一。所以，即使大多数人会同意我们的系统很糟糕，后现代的碎片化本质也让我们像透过万花筒看世界，我们无法就英雄或恶棍、原因或解决方案、你知道，框架
or label, and this fragmentation leads to a sense of disconnection and confusion, a feeling that we're not living an authentic or integrated life. And the task of psychotherapy in this context is to help individuals develop a more coherent and resilient sense of self, you know, one that can withstand the centrifugal forces of modern existence. And psychotherapy can become a new mirror to cancel out those confusing reflections of the kaleidoscope. Because remember, in the kaleidoscope, you're not really seeing something that looks crazy. What makes it look crazy is the fact that it's being reflected at you from 15 different angles, which is something that we can cancel out. We need a new, better
或标签达成一致，这种碎片化导致了一种脱节和困惑感，一种我们没有过上真实或整合的生活的感觉。在这种背景下，心理治疗的任务是帮助个人发展出一种更连贯、更有韧性的自我意识，你知道，一种能够抵御现代存在离心力的自我意识。心理治疗可以成为一面新的镜子，抵消万花筒中那些令人困惑的反射。因为记住，在万花筒里，你并没有真正看到看起来疯狂的东西。让它看起来疯狂的是它从15个不同的角度反射给你，这是我们可以抵消的东西。我们需要一个新的、更好的
functioning understanding of self and psychotherapy for society to see the self and for the self to see clearly our society and the interrelationship between those things. And I think to reclaim the soul and relevance, psychotherapy must reconnect with its philosophical and anthropological roots. You know, these disciplines offer perspectives on the nature of human existence, the formation and meaning of identity, and the cultural contexts that shape our psychological realities in a way that can be very individual. You know, I can teach you how to do this without making you believe the same thing that I believe, which is something that I think psychotherapy has to do. I'm not trying to make you, as a supervisor of therapists, the same therapist as me. I'm not trying to make you, as a patient, similar to me. I'm not even trying to make you get better in the same way I got better. I'm supposed to know the history and the breadth and the context of those
功能性的自我理解和心理治疗，让社会看到自我，让自我清晰地看到我们的社会以及这两者之间的相互关系。我认为要重拾灵魂和相关性，心理治疗必须重新与其哲学和人类学根源连接。你知道，这些学科提供了关于人类存在本质、身份的形成和意义，以及塑造我们心理现实的文化背景的视角，这些视角可以是非常个性化的。你知道，我可以教你如何做到这一点，而不让你相信和我相信的一样的事情，我认为这是心理治疗必须做的。作为治疗师的督导，我不是要让你成为和我一样的治疗师。作为病人，我不是要让你变得和我相似。我甚至不是要让你以我好转的同样方式好转。我应该了解这些
doors, some of which I may have gone through, some of which I may not, but I'm holding space for you to be able to do that in a way that may not be something that I even understand. Many of these, you know, the most influential figures in history of therapy have argued for this. You know, Yalom is a big one. Eric Erickson is a big one. Peter Levin's work, I think, can be read that way. Carl Jung is, you know, Yalom is a big one. Eric Erickson is a big one. Peter Levin's work, I think, can be read that way. Carl Jung is, you know, one that I like and talk about a lot, but him pulling people back into mythology and anthropology, a lot of times a modern myth, a modern anthro. to get them to reflect on the history of meaning making and the history of being human and the history of finding self and soul and the history of healing symptoms to make that something that the patient had some, not just say in how it was done, but ability to do themselves. I think modern therapy has to be teaching people how to be more resilient,
门的历史、广度和背景，有些我可能走过，有些我可能没有，但我为你留出空间，让你能够以一种我甚至可能不理解的方式做到这一点。许多，你知道，治疗史上最有影响力的人物都为此争论过。你知道，亚隆是一个重要人物。埃里克·埃里克森是一个重要人物。我认为彼得·莱文的作品可以这样解读。卡尔·荣格是，你知道，一个我喜欢并经常谈论的人，但他把人们拉回神话和人类学，很多时候是现代神话，现代人类学。让他们反思意义构建的历史、身为人类的历史、寻找自我和灵魂的历史，以及治愈症状的历史，使之成为病人不仅对如何做有发言权，而且有能力自己去做的事情。我认为现代治疗必须教导人们如何更有韧性，
not labeling the resilient patients and the not resilient patients, and then delivering a treatment outcome. It has to find a way to teach people to find an inner strength and an inner ability to heal themselves that I would argue lies dormant in everyone. Whether or not you choose to reconnect with it, it's there. And that's something that a lot of this medical and empirical language has made us forget. So, you know, despite all these profound, a lot of times, still influential tomes that these guys wrote, I mean, yeah, Jung has largely been written off except by people like me, but Yalom wrote the book on two giant chunks of therapy that are still practiced. I mean, if you go out there and you have a textbook about group psychotherapy, it's going to be citing Yalom 90% of the time, and most of it is just going to be
而不是给有韧性的病人和没有韧性的病人贴标签，然后提供治疗结果。它必须找到一种方法来教导人们找到一种内在的力量和一种治愈自己的内在能力，我认为这种能力潜伏在每个人身上。无论你是否选择与它重新连接，它都在那里。这是很多这种医学和经验语言让我们忘记的东西。所以，你知道，尽管这些家伙写了所有这些深刻的、很多时候仍然有影响力的巨著，我的意思是，是的，荣格在很大程度上被除了像我这样的人以外的人否定了，但亚隆写了关于仍然在实践的两大块治疗的书。我的意思是，如果你去外面，你有一本关于团体心理治疗的教科书，它90%的时间都会引用亚隆，而且大部分只是
paraphrasing his book. I mean, there wasn't even another one. No one else said, no, that's actually wrong. This is how you do group therapy. They got any traction. But we won't listen to the ideas where they conflict with the market, which is the problem. So all of these guys, despite their success and their wonderful writing, they weren't listened to, they weren't heard. These ideas aren't mine. A ton of the time people are like, oh, you think you're so smart, you made this podcast. No, I think that I'm really stupid, but I also think that I'm smart enough to be able to read people who are smarter than me and not carry water for things that I was told to believe that I can see are false, you know? You don't really have to be very bright to do that.
转述他的书。我的意思是，甚至没有另一本。没有其他人说，不，那实际上是错的。这就是你做团体治疗的方法。他们得到了任何关注。但我们不会听取与市场冲突的想法，这就是问题所在。所以所有这些人，尽管他们取得了成功和精彩的写作，但他们没有被倾听，没有被听到。这些想法不是我的。很多时候人们会说，哦，你以为你很聪明，你做了这个播客。不，我认为我真的很笨，但我也认为我足够聪明，能够阅读比我聪明的人，而不是为我被告知要相信但我能看出是错误的事情背书，你知道？你真的不需要很聪明就能做到这一点。
You don't really have to be very educated. I certainly am not. But what I am is I'm curious and I'm not ashamed. You're not going to make me stop wanting to learn and you're also not going to make me feel bad about myself. And if you can have that ability, you can synthesize a lot of information in a way that is pretty profound. The relationship between psychology, philosophy, and anthropology is not a matter of academic interest. It's essential to the practice and the effective completion of therapy that has anything to do with meaning. You know, philosophy provides the conceptual tools to grapple with the questions of meaning, ethics, and the nature of consciousness that are often at the heart of psychological distress. Anthropology offers crucial insights into the shaping of identity, the diversity of human experience, and the social context that give rise to, you know, mental health challenges. By reconnecting with these disciplines, you know, psychotherapy can develop a more nuanced and culturally informed approach to healing. And things like this might involve philosophical inquiry, you know, you having like a dialect with a therapist when no one is in control and they're not telling you what to believe, but they're testing your reality so that you have to build your thesis about who and why you are what you are in a way that isn't just intellectual, that is reflectively spiritual some of the time.
你真的不需要受过很好的教育。我当然没有。但我所拥有的是好奇心，而且我不感到羞耻。你不会让我停止想要学习，你也不会让我对自己感觉不好。如果你能拥有这种能力，你就能以一种非常深刻的方式综合大量信息。心理学、哲学和人类学之间的关系不是学术兴趣的问题。它对于任何与意义有关的治疗的实践和有效完成都是必不可少的。你知道，哲学提供了概念工具来处理意义、伦理和意识本质的问题，这些问题往往是心理困扰的核心。人类学提供了关于身份塑造、人类经验的多样性以及导致，你知道，心理健康挑战的社会背景的关键见解。通过与这些学科重新连接，你知道，心理治疗可以发展出一种更细致、更具文化知情的治愈方法。像这样的事情可能涉及哲学探究，你知道，你和治疗师进行对话，当没有人控制，他们不告诉你相信什么，但他们在测试你的现实，这样你就必须建立关于你是谁以及为什么你是你的论文，这种方式不仅仅是智力上的，有时是反思性精神上的。
Maybe draw on some of the anthropological insights, you know, cultural norms and social structures that shape psychology. Develop more holistic models of mental health for sure that talk about mind and body as one, or culture and environment as reflection. Self and environment and self and culture as reflections of one another, deep reflections. We participate in both, you know, with each part of our identity. Fostering, you know, therapists being trained in broader humanistic disciplines. I mean, how many of the colleges, like if you're a therapist, how many of your college classes where you played with baby toys or researched something would have been better off if you had just learned, you know, social anthropology? You know, our best guesses
也许借鉴一些人类学的见解，你知道，塑造心理学的文化规范和社会结构。一定要发展更全面的心理健康模型，谈论身心合一，或者文化和环境作为反射。自我与环境、自我与文化作为彼此的反射，深刻的反射。我们参与其中，你知道，用我们身份的每一部分。培养，你知道，治疗师接受更广泛的人文科学训练。我的意思是，有多少大学，比如如果你是一名治疗师，如果你只是学习了，你知道，社会人类学，你的多少大学课程，那些你玩婴儿玩具或研究某事物的课程，会变得更好？你知道，我们最好的猜测
about what was happening in the Neolithic period and the things that really move society, really move humanity. I mean, one of the things that was the most moving to me as a therapist, as far as not emotionally moving, but moving my understanding of human nature was when I was studying anthropology and they were telling me that, you know, we think in a techno, from a technological, you know, highly specialized society lens that people built cities because it made them more productive. That if we went to cities, then we would have more food, maybe more sex, maybe more kids, better clothing, better quality of life, you know, we could share fuel for heat, all that. That wasn't true. That's what happens post-industrial revolution and sort of post-specialization of like the medieval period. But for the very beginning, that's not what it did. For the very beginning, the reason that we went to cities was because we're building
关于新石器时代发生了什么，以及真正推动社会、真正推动人类的事情。我的意思是，作为一名治疗师，对我来说最感人的一件事，不是情感上的感动，而是改变了我对人性的理解，那就是当我学习人类学时，他们告诉我，你知道，我们从技术、你知道，高度专业化的社会视角认为，人们建造城市是因为它使他们更有效率。如果我们去城市，那么我们会有更多的食物，也许更多的性，也许更多的孩子，更好的衣服，更好的生活质量，你知道，我们可以共享燃料取暖，所有这些。那不是真的。那是工业革命后和中世纪那种专业化之后发生的事情。但从一开始，那并不是它所做的。从一开始，我们去城市的原因是因为我们正在建立
some sort of personal and religious project that makes us congregate and build more and more order and structure. But quality of life went down, access to food went down, health went down. Because when you're coming out of the Stone Age, it doesn't actually make practical, scientific, empirical sense to live in a city. And yet, we congregate because we want to collaborate with knowledge and culture and projects in this way that we're aware that a single person by themself is not as whole as multiple people together. We're not as whole in knowledge. We're not as whole in scientific pursuits. We're not as whole in artistic and
某种个人和宗教项目，使我们聚集在一起，建立越来越多的秩序和结构。但生活质量下降了，食物获取减少了，健康状况下降了。因为当你走出石器时代时，住在城市里实际上并没有实际的、科学的、经验上的意义。然而，我们聚集在一起，因为我们想以这种方式与知识、文化和项目合作，我们意识到一个人自己并不像多个人在一起那样完整。我们在知识上不完整。我们在科学追求上不完整。我们在艺术和
religious pursuits as when all of our creativity is aware of a history that is, at that point, only able to be built through proximity, through oral dissemination of knowledge or very limited writing. And then also, we aren't really as whole spiritually because we're called to build some project that is bigger than us. And when you think about that, and then you say, oh, homo economicus, we're all just these atomized, lonely little things that are completely different from each other, that can be completely disconnected from each other without any sort of negative consequence or problem. I'm an economist. I think that's really scary. And when you say, oh, I believe this about economics and I'm a psychologist, but I don't really want to think about the connection between those things because, I don't know, like the free market just makes you more free and that's why research is good. Or why do you think the Shah of Iran flies here if we don't have the best
宗教追求上不如当我们的所有创造力都意识到一段历史时，那段历史在当时只能通过邻近、通过知识的口头传播或非常有限的书写来建立。而且，我们在精神上也不是真正完整的，因为我们被召唤去建立某种比我们更大的项目。当你想到这一点，然后你说，哦，经济人，我们都是这些原子化的、孤独的小东西，彼此完全不同，可以在没有任何负面后果或问题的情况下彼此完全断开连接。我是经济学家。我认为这真的很可怕。当你问，哦，我相信关于经济学的这一点，我是一名心理学家，但我真的不想考虑这些事情之间的联系，因为，我不知道，就像自由市场让你更自由，这就是为什么研究是好的。或者你为什么认为伊朗国王如果不是因为我们拥有世界上最好的
healthcare in the world? If you can say things like that, you're not doing psychology anyway. So just leave. So as we move out of the postmodern into the metamodern, I think this idea of reconnecting psychology to these two things that are so intrinsic to its scope, you can't disconnect them anyway. Anthropology and philosophy. Trying to find those to build something that can make people not more dependent on the therapist, but more confidently able to depend on themselves. And to make sense of the mess of this world and just the pace of it,
医疗保健，他会飞到这里来吗？如果你能说出这样的话，你反正也不是在做心理学。所以离开吧。因此，当我们从后现代走向元现代时，我认为将心理学重新连接到这两个对其范围如此内在的东西的想法，你反正无法将它们断开。人类学和哲学。试图找到这些东西来建立一些东西，使人们不是更依赖治疗师，而是更自信地能够依赖自己。并理解这个世界的混乱和它的节奏，
to find some sense of connectedness in a deeply disconnected, yet at the same time, atomizationally interconnected world, those are the places where our head needs to be as we try and figure out how to get back to something better
在一个深度断开连接，但同时又在原子化上互联的世界中找到某种连接感，这些是我们试图弄清楚如何回到比我们现在所处的地方更好的地方时，我们需要关注的地方
than where we are right now. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。